country singer Craig Morgan's son is  missing the singer's 19 year old son  Jerry Greer is missing after a boating  accident over the weekend The Tennessean  reports Greer was tubing on the  Tennessee River and fell into the water  but never resurfaced  according to witnesses he was wearing a  life jacket local County Sheriff Chris  Davis told the outlet crews had been  working through the night to locate him  Craig Morgan made his name in country  music with hits like tough and almost  home he also hosts Craig Morgan all  access outdoors on the Outdoor Channel  Jerry had appeared with him on the show  we're gonna try to get Jerry on a big  billy career is one of Morgan's four  children